welcome to the Monster Hunter world
heavy weapon series
great Lord ye old faithful
what the great sword lacks in mobility
it certainly makes up with
earth-shattering damage
it's excellent range and charge slashes
could deal devastating blows to any
monster
[Music]
blunt weighty and savage the hammer is
an excellent choice for those who want a
wallop some monsters bludgeon monsters
over the head to stun them allowing you
to follow up recruit all blows the last
a stout and stoic weapon boasting strong
offensive and defensive capabilities
keeping your guard up while moving
allows you to counter with deadly thrust
attacks
[Music]
gun locks
and the gamblers like its cousin this
weapon is a force to be reckoned with
with its ability to fire off bone
breaking shells to pilaster monster
Hevy bow-gun
for a trade-off in mobility the heavy
bow gun is capable of inflicting massive
damage with his high-powered artillery
be sure to take advantage of powerful
ammo types such as Wyman snipe and wave
in half